Speaker 1: The Senate is soon going to vote
on the confirmation of Joe Biden's Supreme
Court pick.
Katamari Brown Jackson, now she will be confirmed
and it will be an accomplishment for Joe Biden,
rightfully so.
Donald Trump had as an accomplishment.
I mean, he picked horrible people, but he
had as an accomplishment, not only getting
a bunch of judges confirmed to lower courts,
as has Joe Biden, but Trump also had three
Supreme Court justices to his name.
And they are accomplishments.
I mean, let's be honest, they are disastrous
justices who have pulled the Supreme Court
more to the right than it's been in a very
long time.
But if you're a right wing nut, you like it
and you see it as an accomplishment.
So when?
Not if, when Judge Jackson is confirmed to
the Supreme Court, it will be an accomplishment
for President Joe Biden, and maybe he will
get more opportunities.
But we are now starting to hear from Republicans
about whether they will support the confirmation.
Now, you know, and I know and anybody who
takes the time to look knows that Judge Jackson
is as qualified as any of the nine justices
currently on the court with a wider breadth
of experience than any justice on the court.
The closest is Stephen Breyer, who she would
be replacing.
But it still appears many Republicans, maybe
even most, are going to be voting no.
We don't yet know whether Mitt Romney will
vote to confirm Judge Jackson.
Susan Collins, Republican from Maine, has
said she will vote to confirm Judge Jackson,
and her explanation is so simple it's she
has the experience and she has the qualifications.
That's it.
And it really should be that simple.
But I'm going to give you an example of the
worst of the worst.
Here's a clip of Republican Senator Roy Blunt.
This is almost beyond parody.
He was interviewed by George Stephanopoulos
on ABC yesterday, and he says that Jackson
should be confirmed and it will be a great
accomplishment that she will be confirmed.
It will be a high point for the country, but
he's not going to support that confirmation.
And when George Stephanopoulos asks, well,
why he delivers an unintelligible word salad
reminiscent of Sarah Palin, who, by the way,
we'll talk about a little bit later today.
Listen to this
Speaker 2: thing, which a Judge Katju Tunji
Brown's Jackson if you made up your mind.
Yet while I have a George and I'm going to
be with you this morning, you know, I've thought
initially my sense is that the president certainly
had every good intention and every every right
in the campaign to talk about putting the
first black woman on the court.
I think it's time for that to happen.
I was hoping that I could be part of that.
I had a great conversation with her.
Really, there are two criterias I said immediately.
One is is the person qualified for the job
and two is what's her judicial philosophy?
OK.
She's certainly qualified.
I think he's got a great personality I think
will be a good colleague on the court.
But the judicial philosophy is seems to be
not the philosophy of looking at what the
law says and the Constitution says and applying
that.
But going through some method that allows
you to try to look at the Constitution as
a more flexible document, and even now,
Speaker 1: I wish that were true.
It's not true.
And it was actually surprising to many progressives
how centrist on the questions of judicial
philosophy and seeing the Constitution more
as a sacred text versus a living document,
how how centrist her answers were.
This is just not true.
Roy Blunt is saying,
Speaker 2: Bend the law and there are cases
that show that that's her view.
I think she's certainly going to be confirmed.
I think it'll be a high point for the country
to see her go on the court and take her unique
perspective to the court.
But I don't think she's the kind of judge
that will really do the kind of work that
I think needs to be done.
Speaker 1: What on earth is he talking about?
He likes the fact that there's going to be
the first black woman on the court.
He says that her qualifications are without
question.
But he's not big on her judicial philosophy,
which he claims without evidence nor citing
a single example that she's not strict enough
about her interpretation of the Constitution.
But there's no substance there.
It sounds like basically the only things he's
defending are reasons to vote for her confirmation
as
Speaker 2: the court, and I won't be supporting
her, but I'll be joining others and understanding
the importance of this moment.
If it's a high point for the country, why
not support her, right?
Well, I think the lifetime appointments have
a different criteria than other appointments.
I've supported a significant number of President
Biden's nominees to the offices that will
end their time will end while he's still in
office or when he leaves office.
I think that's a different criteria than somebody
putting somebody on the court for.
Life, I don't think I've but
Speaker 1: you're still not really giving
an example of what it is about her answers
that concerned you, so this is mealy mouthed,
to say the least.
And quite frankly, it might be just as simple
as I'm not going to vote for her because my
supporters will be mad and I don't want to
anger my supporters.
A lot of the Republicans who are saying they're
not going to vote for her don't even really
seem to know why they're not going to vote
for her.
They they seem to sometimes rattle off something
about sentencing for people in possession
of explicit child sexual images.
But even then, it's not even really clear
what they thought the sentences should be
in certain cases.
It's all very weird.
And there's a report from Business Insider
which indicates that Mitch McConnell, the
Republican Senate minority leader, has been
pushing other Republican senators to also
not support Judge Jackson.
So we will wait and see.
She's going to be confirmed by absolutely
every indication.
The question is how many Republicans are actually
going to support her and on qualifications?
There is nothing there in terms of a valid
reason not to support her